now salt Hank Albert can cook and Owen
Han are amongst the world's biggest
sandwich artists in 20 bloody minutes
there is a lot of pressure shut up it's
the battle of the internet food Giants
here at Caesar Palace in Las Vegas as
they compete to be crowned my idiot
[Music]
sandwich Jens are you ready let's do it
salt Hank are you ready yeah I'm good
Vegas are you ready yeah
your time starts
now today the sandwich kings are
battling out to prove who has the
ultimate idiot sandwich VI counts won't
be deciding who wins this challenge
taste will let's go let's go let's go so
this is The Ultimate Showdown three
phenomenal chefs all creating three
extraordinary sandwiches now I think the
pressure is on Owen more than anybody
else because this guy is a super
talented sandwich maker Albert a man of
very few words but boy does he pack a
punch salt Hank uh this man's been
crafting his expertise these sandwiches
let me tell you so I think you're in for
something unique uh Owen how you doing
bud good immediately starting with the
pickling liquid cuz that'll take the
most amount of time I love that give me
an inside of the sandwich what we doing
first it's an Asian style Philly cheese
steak Beijing beef pickled onions
mozzarella and uh yeah pickled peppers
and onions now all the crowd are saying
it's yours to lose um do you feel under
more pressure or can you handle that um
truthfully there is a lot of pressure
but I think we'll be good working in the
studio with multiple hours multiple
cameras I'm always taking my time now
you're live you got 20 minutes can you
can you can you can you deliver I think
we'll be good but this is very new to me
so you got this man you got this right
uh my man how you feeling I'm good man
I'm scar I'm terrified you Ramsey
standing right next to you are off to a
great start tell me about the sandwich
what are you doing uh so we're
caramelizing onions right now I got uh
some wores sure and wine in here some in
there well wores sure and are you going
to try and ask me to say wor sure come
on that's that's that's
not I think it's the mustache that's
getting in the
way
exactly wor wory and some red wine and
then uh we're going to get some uh buan
and beef stock in the pot I love that
boil that down with some mirp I love
that tell me the sandwi what a fres dip
okay French dip everybody give hand come
on guys are you nervous you're never
nervous come on I'm terrified are you
kidding me this is horrifying Jordan
Ramsay asking you if you're nervous
standing next to you watching you cook
it's like the craziest dilemma listen
you got the best knives the best pant
the live audience what more do you want
the roll Roy of pant right don't say
that don't say that Rolls-Royce are the
hexclad of cars yes there
is next step mushrooms you have some
mushroom you need to chop
them this is
that's that ain't going to work our 10
Alber the man how's it going perfect
Beef Wellington be you doing it Beef
Wellington yeah in 20 bloody
minutes give it up for Alba by the way
oh man I mean Ian I'm making a sandwich
yeah I know but have you get a beef when
sandwich in 20 minutes he will see what
easy easy easy seriously yeah um what do
you think about the competition cuz look
at Owen just look at the concentration
on his face yeah he he's he's he really
wants to win you know yeah um you're
blowing up on those social channels I'm
loving the work you're doing but let's
be honest back home you've got hours and
hours and hours today you got 20
minutes yeah you you you going to do
this yeah you sure yeah I cannot wait to
taste this won sandwich not salt Hank
what a guy you talking I was
actually complimenting you but a what a
cutie no he actually can cook he knows
his stuff uh-oh this is going to make me
look weak wait uh-oh but I feel like
we're both similar in the sense that we
there we go cook by feel we got some
beef boang all right steaks are going in
where' I put halfway guys come on give
us
some
halfway where did I actually put the
steaks um three extraordinary sandwiches
by the way uh Albert serus okay this guy
is coming in he's got his aame he's
doing a Wellington sandwich that's right
a Wellington sandwich in 20 minutes he's
using a beautiful riy it's looking good
I'm just slightly nervous that Alba's
going to run out of time Owen his
sandwich sounds incredible again he's
got a beautiful RI uh he's slicing that
thing up he's got a lot of heat in there
acid with the pickles it's going to be
super competitive I'm going to go grab
the
bread uh salt Hank um yeah this guy's
going down a completely different rout
however I just hope that salt Hank gets
his beef on First and gets that thing
rested before he starts slicing
it 9 minutes to
go all right what's oh sauce got to get
the sauce so I just want to add some
some flavor to it nice big glob of
mayonnaise there look at that so
basically we have all ingredients and we
done just
assemble so I decided to make pickled
onions and chilies but I'm worried that
I will not have enough time to
mushroom some flavor hey Owen how's it
going actually really well 5 minutes
remaining come on five minutes Al there
you good done you good I'm done yeah
you're done already yeah oh you can you
can use the last five minutes and tght
that thing up a little bit yeah yeah
yeah just just to make it more I love
that I love that please no crying yes
you got this Al oh in 5 minutes to go
I'm trying to melt the cheese cuz the
broiler love that a little bit of steam
there we go yeah happy with the pickling
uh it's a quick pickle right very quick
pickle it's fine it will do the job yeah
the acid will be there it'll work well
and what's the source how you going to
bring this thing together it's uh in the
marinade with the meat so it's Beijing
beef oyer sauce sugar soy sauce a little
bit of sesame oil love that love that 3
and a half minutes to
go right uh my man how you feeling how
we doing uh oh nice nice that lovely
color on that I do like you want to base
that for me actually you like me to base
that of course I'll I'll base that
absolutely feel these though yeah
they're still rare but that's good right
yeah R is good yeah cuz we're going to
broil it afterwards gotcha J got time
I'm a little bit terrified how are you
going to assemble this we'll figure it
out 3 minutes to go ladies and gentlemen
come on Albert's already ahead of his
time the Wellington sandwich is done
salt Hank is running a little bit behind
he's basing those filet good Owen is in
front of it honestly a little bit water
in that pan to steam that cheese and
fingers Crossing going to start
assembling that any second now yeah yeah
I charred the out of these onions Al are
you happy a lot of Che good man all this
it's all about the presentation in these
final seconds um and this is the makeer
break situation 90 seconds to go we're
slicing our steak but it's still very
hot salt H don't forget the salt come on
my man looking good looking very good
it's raw salt 60 seconds to go guys come
on give some love let's go let's go so
come on man let's go let me cook 30
seconds to
go salt Han start assembling please
please please please come on guys we go
g where 20 seconds to go let's go salt
please we're running out of time man
come
on assemble 5 4 3 2 1 and
stop oh my goodness
me and now for the favorite part of this
challenge the taste test Let's Go Round
of Applause for Hank please come on
guys okay my man you got a lot going on
describe that dish please so this is a
French dip we got some caramelized
onions which accidentally had some tring
on them a lot of meat nothing wrong with
that should we get in and make sure you
don't forget to dip it I promise you now
soak that a you up we are in Vegas we
will dip it good okay let's have a look
inside let's have a look and
crosssection
oh yes I like that that looks good that
looks very good ladies and gentlemen
would you like a
bite oh my God my man all right I go in
first please and so French dip you go
off you go well I just want to make make
sure you know how much to dip yeah but
thank you for telling me how much to dip
I appreciate that okay wet
and uh-oh uh-oh no come on uhoh this is
the moment the truth here it's good it's
good it's very good it's good it's good
good all right you don't even need a
taste there we're good show's
over I love it I love it love it well
done give it up for
soank now the man of very few words but
confident right you asked me for EO
sandwich yeah yeah yeah I asked so it
has to be well fingers crossed I've
never had a Welling in sandwi but I love
the ambition we got R we got Master we
have par we have uh what else oh we have
we have cand for flavor puff pastry
flavor uh puff pastry flavor where
what's Quon for puff pastry have you
been smoking oh yeah puff pastry isn't
really quason but it's very buttery yeah
I mean I mean it's close it's very close
yeah there's no there's no yeast in puff
pastry but however Albert we are not we
are not going to argue with you let's
get inside I don't know yeah a good oh
that is good um what did you cook the
mushrooms in olive oil
olive oil mhm olive
oil okay tastes okay it's so good to see
you
happy I didn't expect the taste okay I
didn't make it before you never made
this before no wow honestly not too
salty no it's not too salty no
no I like it least smile again one more
time for
me give it up for hour ladies
[Applause]
gentl right uh Owen how you feeling feel
good you good yeah man that was a rapid
20 minutes um describe that for me
please we have an Asian style cheese
steak in a way this sandwich is almost
like me Chinese and Italian wow I love
that it's a great combination uh you've
cut it uh already uh I love the look
okay uh it's ooy uh it is
incredibly fragrant love that and what's
the spice what's the Heat um from the uh
Fresno chilies Fresno chilies in the pck
shall we look good yeah shall we would
you like a bite
anybody well you can't cuz I'm tasting
them uh cheers
bud I love the heat fres no chili
definitely clearly
identified but melt in the mouth is
coming together that uh delicious give a
round of applause please L and
gentlemen
wow three extraordinary sandwiches only
one can be crowned at idiot sandwich
please come over this is it ladies and
gentlemen I have to be honest these
three men definitely know their
sandwiches let me tell you uh idiot
sandwich goes
[Music]
to come
on oh
yeah what are you an idiot sandwich
louder an idiot
sandwich thank you so much for watching
these amazing idiots Please Subscribe
for more and if you'd like a chance to
roasted by me then use the hash idiot
[Applause]
sandwich